[Music]
I'm here with Alastair Alastair great to
have you on the show thank you we met
last year in September we certainly did
yep then you did the crash course and
different things like that and now
you're a deal sorcerer yeah and the
purpose of this video is to talk about
how to be a successful dear sorcerer how
to be compliant and just generally
mindset and tips for success
okay so I you're right we didn't meet in
September last year at the crash course
yeah I did do some follow training all
about finding deals accept to accept
drop and are then went on to do some
slipping which is your term for
packaging and sailing deals and I after
a few months of doing that so you're
comped I went on started my own company
with yourself and yeah it's been it's
been an awesome journey so you're
financially free now yes your wife is
financially free you made how much money
did you make in the last month and the
last month through deal source and I my
properties me just just under 27,000
pounds
27,000 pounds in a month which is not
bad I think it's really good you
sourcing lease option agreement you saw
some rent to rent below market value
HMOs what is the number one tip or
secret to being such a successful deal
sorcerer I think you've just got to put
yourself in the game so if you're gonna
look in to be a common deal soar so you
need to get out there looking at houses
you're not going to find them sitting
behind a computer looking at right move
you need to actually physically get out
one of the things that you're really
passionate about is it really angers you
to see people selling deals when no
one's seen the house they just relied on
what the vendor or an estate agent has
said yeah you're really passionate about
view now one thing I I don't agree with
is you see advertised all social media
things that people just find right move
links and they just ping them out as
deals they've not actually viewed the
houses they're possibly not even
compliant sorcerers and I I'm very
passionate about being compliant so so
because I personally wouldn't give my
money to somebody if they weren't
compliant because you've got no recourse
yes exactly so what is it do you comply
and then and compliance is actually it's
not difficult it's quite straightforward
you need sort of three or four things so
you need insurance professional
indemnity insurance
it also covers your vehicle because
you're gonna be using your vehicle to
loot properties you need to be part of
one the property redress scheme so it's
the property ombudsman the property
redress scheme or the Ombudsman services
scheme
I'm personally with the property
Ombudsman I think they're the best and
well not most well-known and for that
you'll have to upload your insurance
certificate and then you've also got
data protection license which is about
forty pounds and an anti money
laundering certificate so it sounds like
quite a lot of stuff but you're saying
it's relatively straightforward
it's it'll take you a morning's work to
get everything in place it'll cost you
between twelve and fifteen hundred
pounds which is going to be more than
paid for in your first day one deal one
deal one deal will cover it so where do
you fall on the deals then but you're
passing on I find the deals on various
on online estate agents direct vendor I
send out a lot of information and
letters directly to vendors and they get
information from that also other sites
which aren't the more common sites for
looking at houses that are so not little
right move that Gumtree there's always
always deals to be found and Gumtree and
also if I see like a couple for sale
signs up there more than one typically I
wouldn't put a lettuce with the the door
or I'll put business cards through the
door yeah and one of the things that I
really love about your strategy is your
strategies to just meet people new
houses talk to people because you find
so many deals just by networking when
when I am looking at deals I'm always
listening so don't just I don't I'm not
there to tell the vendor my story I want
to listen to their story yeah and I find
a lot of my deals have come from just
listening so like my lease options have
come by listening to vendors that were
trying to sell their houses I went out
to look at a right rent to rent property
and that ended up being a lease option
because it suited the vendor a lot
better than a rent to rent because he
wants to sell it when he's 75 he's no 69
so we hashed out together a lease option
he's getting a fantastic deal and
getting a good deal and it's a it's a
great deal so your lease option
agreement you had to pay the solicitor
fees yep which is about seven eight
hundred pounds yes it's about a grand
with the VAT
with the VAT okay how much more money
did you have to put in raises all that
I've got when I'm Wilbur Hampton and
that's going to cost
no that's bit about a grand and in a
little bit of refurbishment so maybe two
grand for refurbishment
so I would say three grand all in and
then I'm leasing the furniture I'm not
buying it so three grand all in yeah
no deposit no deposit no fee to the to
the landlord and from that three grand
that you're putting in that's going to
mean that you have an option to buy the
house in how many years five years time
in five years time for presumably a good
a good price yeah it says it's more than
it's worth at the minute
the vendors happy with it doing it as a
the vendor was going to rain tire anyway
for the next five years and he was going
to be making I would say 20 20 K over
the next five years and I've the way the
deal we've done because the the profit
in it he's going to be getting about an
extra twenty five thousand pound over
five years Christ so he's happy he's
over the moon how are you making profit
from that then because I'm letting it's
already a student accommodation so he
wasn't doing it properly he just
basically had three three or four
students just late in it and there were
pin like six hundred pound a month for
the whole house yeah I'm now gonna do it
correctly I'm gonna use quick move to
manage property who are advising me
correctly about it and we're gonna do as
a four-bed multi late it's already got
fired or it's already what fire alarm
system just needs a little bit of
painting some carpets and that area I
personally have got a lot of HMOs you
know I know that it's gonna rent up
really well it's in a nice area yeah and
you know the area really well you've
done your research how much profit are
you gonna be making each month then 750
to 800 pound and I'm conservative I want
more but I'm happy if I get so you're
gonna put three grand in yeah you're
gonna make about 800 pounds a month
profit yeah and then in five years time
you've got the option to buy not the
obligation so you can walk away yeah but
you're gonna have the option to buy it
how much 125 125 which is not it's
probably gonna be a lot more my
prediction and I think we're more of a
Hampton if all the Hampton continues
going up the way it is you'll have an
absolute bargain then and that's just
one of your lease option agreement its
but you have got others I've got another
one yet and and also some in the
pipeline I've got three in the pipeline
at the minute incredible how do you find
lease option agreement deals by
listening to vendors yeah that's honest
there can't reiterate enough I go out a
look at houses and I listen to vendors
because most vendors have a story to why
they sell in our house and if you can
make the deal better for them it's not
about me being a greedy investor it's
not about me trying to steal their
properties it's about me being helpful
and trying to make it so they make more
money yeah I can make more money and
they can get a deal that suits them then
why wouldn't they do it one of the
things I love about you is I mean you've
been you've been through the through the
training with myself and you just do
exactly what I say yeah who the T I'm a
massive implement or so basically if I
learn a new strategy I'm out Monday
morning doing that strategy yeah I don't
I don't read about it for three weeks
I'm out doing it so we learn about rent
rents or on our 2d course I was only was
Friday and Saturday yeah I had Sunday at
home with a wife and in Monday morning I
was on the way to Oxford to look at
three rental rents that's incredible
they didn't come off unfortunately but
good experience and then I've got more
that have laid on from that so it's
brilliant and all of your training has
been through my company it's all been
through the Academy what would you say
to somebody that said well I'm not going
to pay you to source me a property
you've only been in the game six months
what are you okay what I know is my
experience I've looked at over 100
houses in the last six months so if
you're not looking at houses you saw
you'll get more experience by looking at
houses and you will read in any book you
start looking and you start getting on
the road and started implement and
you'll gain so much more it's been so
much faster than people that just sit
looking and write move also although
you've only got a six months experience
a lot of people say they've got 20 years
experience
yeah really they've got one years
experience photograph 20 times yeah I
agree and you have only been in the game
six months but you've done so much and
you've paid a lot of money to learn from
other people's mistakes
yeah so actually you haven't got years
and years in the industry but you've
certainly got enough experience to find
a good deal listen I've got six months
six to eight months in the property
industry but I've got ten years in
business
yeah and Simon was very right about what
he says I had a business and I started
it and I just copied it for seven years
and it was good it provided me a living
but it didn't ever make me super
successful yeah I've learned more in the
last six months and I learnt in the last
seven years and that's why I can find
properties and that's why I've got
investors not falling at my feet but
I've got investors coming on board every
day they are falling at your feet you've
got a whole queue I was at the circle I
was at you run the property investor
circle yeah
running property investor so how did he
go last night it was awesome about
stochastic that's sixty people in the
room yeah and it was your cuz I put like
push people right yeah so the thing I'm
pushing you gone so that the pic meeting
was it was my stepping out of my comfort
zone I I've never been that not much of
a confident person and so stepping out
of my comfort zone which is what Samuel
Taylor me and pushes me every single
time am iam
sometimes I hate it yeah sometimes I'm
really uncomfortable but you know what
I'm not growing I would rather be
uncomfortable in grow yeah then
comfortable and boring that's incredible
so I would just tell everybody just do
you know what you might tell you to do
some stupid stuff just do it and I hope
you didn't want me saying but the first
time I had you introduce me onstage
wasn't that great no it sucked your mind
went blank yeah I mean you're only
supposed to be on stage for a minute or
two but it was it was really tough yeah
but then after a little bit of practice
a little bit of coaching and watching
other people do it you absolutely killed
it the second time you did it and the
circle that you ran last night 60
investors in the room I'm at the back of
the room I don't say a word but you
absolutely have complete control over
the room that means a lot and because
yes you're right the first time I
introduced you sucked it did and I told
you it sucks yeah I told no you're very
honest yeah I did hear you and Russell
laughing in the corridors doing it
that's good I don't mind that yeah
rather be told that it sucked present I
can learn from it and then when we tell
you it's good you know that we're
telling the complete truth yeah so you
killed it yesterday and the feedback has
been incredible yeah you hosted it
really well facilitated it really well
we had people doing networking sessions
people doing business people finding
deals people getting mortgages set up
from Kevin it was absolutely incredible
so um why don't you plan Sonia you come
out to Africa with me on Monday yeah
Monday morning I'm flying out to Africa
because one of the you take the so light
as if it's one of the things you do
every month you know yeah I'm off to
Africa on Monday what does your wife
think about that and my wife was
actually really really looking forward
to coming but we with charities it's a
bit difficult but yeah she's gonna come
out next year I'm definitely coming back
next year yeah it's not that you're not
financially you're both financially free
now it's just childcare caulker issues
not costs yeah
leave my daughter for two weeks that's
understandable it's a small family
because we're going out to Africa on
Monday because I think it's really
important when you stop making money
that you very very quickly get into the
habit of being able to give yeah and
that I think that's one of the things
that attracted you about do you know I
remember at the crash course at timber
last year and we watched that video of
what you do in Africa and that little
boy not having time for food I mean that
if Sam I think about it that like I have
to stop talking because it it pills at
my heartstrings but that same little boy
in the video has now got a clean
drinking water river well thanks to you
you're gonna meet him next week oh you
are yeah you'll meet him next week
and we're sending him to a private
school really yeah that is awesome that
little boy who who I met for the first
time in April last year so yeah and I
just think it's really important not
only to not only to personally for
myself to give back and help people to
make a difference where you can but also
to encourage my students to do it yeah
in fact certainly the advanced students
I'll be a lot I'll even say you know I'm
not going to teach you anything unless
you're gonna be prepared to but you give
I don't mind given I honestly don't
because the there's got to be a bigger
reason in your life to just send them
money you've got bill to do something so
having all this money but you got to do
with it yeah exactly you can't take it
when you die I know you can pass it on
to children you can build all these
houses but there's people in the world
that have nothing and and mmm for me a
big reason for me come to Africa is I
want to find a bigger purpose to my life
than just making money and just looking
after my immediate family so you know
what I I think it's gonna change your
life because I think it's Jim Rohn who
says looking after yourself is okay yeah
looking after yourself and your wife
that's good looking after yourself your
wife in your family is brilliant but
what is absolutely extraordinary is when
you can then go even far greater than
that and you can look after your
immediate family but then also go
further than that so that's great
taking a whole team out you've got a
bunch coming out from the Academy yeah
Florin yeah
who's doing deals as well making good
with it but they're all coming out
because it didn't deals yeah yeah it's
like a reward that Samuel offers like we
do deals Samuel helps us with he invites
us to these events so you've got M
Stewart Browns coming out at Florin yeah
s3 and
so we just saw an an and mother and John
and Joe and John repo and we're always
taking out some of the staff Nick's come
in muscles come in and I'm looking
forward to doing this bunch jump I hear
the bridge is broken right yeah I look I
just I'm so good about that I think I'm
the only person that's good it when I'm
gutted I am oh yeah of course you are
who you are because I know that Stewart
and John were gonna do it but they were
they were pulling themselves they only
told me that we're gonna do after we
found that the bridge was broken oh yeah
no we'll probably do some water rafting
instead something that's fine own
adrenaline sports we're gonna go down to
the villages business workshops for the
entrepreneurs then we're heading to
where Oh South Africa Johannesburg
Robert Kiyosaki yeah dinner with Robert
Kiyosaki we've got to the wealth summit
and conference two days so obviously
we're going to that and we're gonna have
to be having dinner with him on one of
the evenings yeah which is it's gonna be
a great little event
yeah great opportunity to have a couple
minutes with them just see how I tell me
yeah and get a photo get four graph yeah
just meet one of the best investors in
the world yeah you think the pinnacle of
our industry so why not yeah absolutely
he is going to meet the guy and he's a
real inspiration Robert Kiyosaki for
thousands and thousands of people Robert
Kiyosaki was actually the guy I read the
rich dad put Rich Dad Poor Dad book and
then that led me on to some leads by
Lorraine hi book Wow a lot of people say
that yeah Stewart Stewart's the same you
it was on the beach in Greece yeah
reading Robert Kiyosaki's Rich Dad Poor
Dad
and then he was reading my book and he'd
never met me and then he said if he
didn't know that within a year he'd be
having dinner with both me and Robert
Kiyosaki he'd have pinched himself same
as if I'd known in January of this year
that I would be in July
sitting here with Samuel and meeting
Robert Kiyosaki is it's awesome
yeah I think now means having the really
good friends and like six months ago
it's I have to pinch myself sometimes
that like real good friends and that
we've got like we're going to meet
Robert Kiyosaki we're doing all these
deals and six-month school has changed
my life is completely different and last
week last weekend we were having dinner
with Sylvester Stallone 100% yeah it's
also and you got a picture to prove it
yeah man himself Rocky Balboa it
birthday yeah robbery shoulders with
celebrities six months ago would never
believe I would never have listened to
anyone say yeah you're gonna be doing
all so you you you you went on the cross
goes to September and you started
implementing stuff and you said that by
the time you came to the advanced
training in January yes from September
to January you paid for the advanced
training upfront yeah and by January
you'd already paid for the training as a
result of what you'd learned on the
crash course yes or on the crash course
and I think it's day to simon teaches
you all but simplifying your finances
about having six bank accounts learning
management money management what stuff
and i actually implemented it so on the
way home i opened by on the train on the
way home I opened my six bank account
yeah and done it with not waste they can
do it you can do very easily online and
I started doing the saving side of
things but more importantly for me was I
actually simplified my account I went on
and I just essentially just cancelled if
think I didn't recognize and you know
what not many people support to me no no
they were wrong made to say you know why
you canceled it not that little piece
alone I probably spend like half an hour
on that and I've got a credit TR Becca
and also I can't remember the guys name
of the guy who wrote the richest man in
Babylon for that for that piece I think
I do at the crash course but I'll as you
referenced it yeah it's a great it's a
great theory because I saved mean me and
Lisa are we could we add spending habit
so you know we were to spend the money
that yeah like just gone out for dinner
when you didn't need to they memberships
of a gym in the gym side because when
you came in January I remember you said
to me I've already paid for this
training off off the back of what we
learned on the crash course and I was
like high five and I think I got a
little video be there and then saying
that why did you decide to go down the
route of lease option agreements rent to
rent deal sourcing as opposed to other
strategies okay when I started doing the
Academy and doing the further training
I wasn't lauded I didn't have loads of
money I had three or four thousand
pounds in the bank and I don't know if
you guys know you cannot buy a house
with three or four thousand pounds
conventionally so you have to be a bit
more creative so that's why I originally
started doing this lipping ordeal
sourcing just to get a little bit of
cash going back in to pay for my
investment in the training and I've done
that very quickly and then I went
decided to stop me stop me on sourcing
company and I like the idea of lease
options just because I didn't have that
massive port of money I'm very very I'm
very careful about lease options because
I don't want to be ripping anybody off I
want it done properly it's got to be
good for everybody there is some
charlatans out there that will take
advantage of lease options I'm not one
of them and I suggest everyone that's
listening to this does it properly
because I know the way I teach Lease
Option agreements there's there's a
process yes before you go in for that
for the deal
yeah did you find it difficult to go
through that process did you find would
it have been easy to try and cut corners
yeah if you if um it's very easy as a
new investor to like just when I jump in
and see I've got this great offer for
you do want to do it but no you have to
restrain you have to exhaust the options
you have to just ensure that you're not
pulling the wool over these people's
eyes but yeah that's their property at
the end of the day and they could be my
parents and I would be gutted if
something done that to my parents if
they didn't look after them properly so
yeah I made sure that I looked after my
meet you they were very very clear we
had lots of phone calls
lots of timeless lists over they were
speaking to the solicitor that we
recommend and just just to make sure
that everything they were a hundred cent
happy and that they knew what we'll get
into yeah now I'm in regular contact
with both my vendors did this become a
lot Paul just takes me this morning to
tell me that he's he's um he wants to
come and pick up a chair that you left
in the house and it's great do you mean
we're getting on really well we're not
it's not like you're a rich investor and
you try to take my house we're doing it
as I mutual sort of business agree
that's brilliant and also everyone wants
different things so sometimes a
motivated seller might just not want the
stress or the emotional attachment of
the house anymore for whatever reason
but that was exactly with Paul Paul he's
come to an age where he doesn't really
want to be managing property managers
himself and he wasn't getting the
maximum over the property he was willing
getting like six hundred pounds a month
for a four-bed multi lit which is not
really great and I've come along after
I'm renovating the property and I'm I'm
maximizing it I'm making as much sort of
out of it as we can get and he's getting
a confident he's getting our an amount
that was very similar to what he was
getting before I took on but I'm
guaranteeing to buy often and
have you had any issues with I mean
because you've had a complete life
transformation in the last six months
yeah going from working full-time your
wife working regular jobs to now
suddenly meeting all these celebrities
financially free making 27,000 pounds in
a month yeah what's been the
repercussions from your family your
friends how they dealt with these
generally really supported they don't
understand it but that's fine I get that
my parents of had a bombshell dropped on
them recently about what I'm doing so
the their fame of that and you build
those friends over this but do you know
what they were never your true friends
if you don't support you yeah I've lost
a couple of friends over it but I always
say to my students you know if you're
successful you start making good money
you're gonna have people that are gonna
fall out of you some people are going to
be jealous some people just not going to
understand it they're gonna think that
oh you're gonna change now or you're
certainly going to become really
arrogant and then their defense to that
will be to start treating you
differently one of my friends said to me
just doesn't get why I'm doing it and I
said you don't need to get it it's not
your it's not your dream it's my dream
yeah all you need to do to support me
and and just be there if I if I've got
problems you'd be there and he still
doesn't get it he do you know as his
problems not my problem why are you
doing it because why am i doing it
because I think there's more to life
than work in nine-to-five I want to
spend a lot more time my family and I
want to be able to not worry about my
family's financial future I want to know
that if I want to Spain if I don't take
a month off to spend it with my family
because my wife's missing me a little
bit I can I don't have to worry about it
yeah and there's more to life is it's
not just about the money it keeps in
money's great don't get me wrong when
he's fantastic but you've got bill do
something with it
what sport and having all those money in
your bank if you've got nobody explained
it with or if you've got ya know like
people to give back to so one of the
reasons I'm so happy to come to Africa
is I want to give give something back I
want to go I'm not saying I'm gonna be
out there building water wells at the
minute but if I can give just a little
bit for the time being it will grow and
it will get bigger and bigger and bigger
I really love that have you done any
other property training prior to my
training no I read a few books I did
gonna do a couple of sort of them like
one day sort of events about the freedom
yeah that I'm not gonna mention who they
were but I did do a few one day sort of
events how are they compared with the
crash course I I didn't like them I
found them from the minute you walked in
the door they were they were trying to
sort of sell you their next program they
were trying to do that and I didn't find
very much value and I thought what they
would do is they would say this is one
strategy and just as you were getting
interested they would say they would
move on to the next strategy you never
actually got a complete front to end
strategy you always go yeah he's a
little bit but if you really want to
know you need to pay yeah he must be
fresh course like the crash course is
two days of like just awesome value
awesome content like you're not just
sitting there you're not in a stuffy
room listening to a small you're not in
a stuffy room listening to slides are
watching slideshows and wrist listening
to boring speakers
you've got Samuel on stage who's like
buzzing of energy as it is you've got
lots of people in the room that are all
keen to be there we're doing lots of
deals we're doing lots of falling estate
agents when you're not just sitting
there getting bored there's lots and
lots going on it's entertaining but also
you learn you're learning what would you
say to people that are worried about
they've been on a couple of free courses
before well they're just it's just been
one big sales pitch because of course on
the first to say that there will be an
offer yeah cuz if I if someone came to
the two days crash course and there was
no opportunity to do further advanced
training or mentoring then I wouldn't be
serving them yeah so there of course
there's going to be an opportunity for
advanced training but is it a big
massive sales pitch no no no seriously
right I was I was at crash course last
weekend and we started at 9:30 in the
morning and we went onto like 6:30 all
talking about what we're doing all
talking about finding deals doing deals
real estate agents everything content
and then yes time has a small offer to
make it's not forced upon you it's not
driven down your throat it's a small
offer if you want to do it that's great
if you don't want to do it you don't
have to do it yeah I've got 12 like
we'll be in the room for 12 hours yeah a
lot of it is all about content and then
98% content and value and then 2% making
it's a free event it's completely free
to attain apart from the booking fee
unless you upgrade to VIP but for
free of n for not is phenomenal value
phenomenal I think that I wouldn't
begrudge paying to 300-pound to come to
that event because of what you learn on
events yeah yeah some people say that
they've spent 10 15 grand on training
and they've looked more on the two days
at the crash course honestly I was
speaking to a guy who spend I'm not
going to say the name of a company but
he told me spent 14 thousand pound on
the training event and he told me
message me on Facebook after the last
last month's crash course and said he
learnt more on two days of the crash
course 14,000 fun event there's always
good and bad in every industry yeah and
unfortunately some of the bad people
some of the bad trainers some of the bad
sources who aren't compliant or who are
don't don't deliver good value they just
want to grab your money and run
yeah they end up giving other people in
the industry a bad name but I personally
think that I I get so much satisfaction
from teaching yeah just from seeing
people like yourself because you're not
there's many people like yourself right
yeah it's not just me there's a lot we
were in a room at ok we're doing this
interview but we're actually at an event
at the minute and there's multiple
people in the room about borders Lords
yeah they're all they're all getting on
there we're on our way and our petty
people doing Lease Option agreements
like Chris is just secured a big leagues
opportunity given him 1,200 pounds
profit a month there's too many to even
mention there's Lords what what what do
you think about I know you're quite
passionate you get quite upset with some
of these really bad sources going around
and these just just people given the
industry a bad name what would you say
to Matt smug bear is when I open
facebook and nor ands or whenever I look
at Facebook and all you see is all these
people advertising deals that just not
deals I've seen one today where it's a
lease option the guy wants a 5,000 pound
finder's fee to make positive cash flow
180 pounds a month that's not a deal to
me that sucks
yeah and who would buy that you need to
begin at least a 100 percent return on
investment when buying a lease option
agreement yeah I know if you're making
200 pound a month you shouldn't really
be spending more than about 2 grand yeah
for that for the deal yeah for the
finder's fee but this this property
wanted a 5k finder's fee four and a half
K refurb you're talking 10k to me and
one little boy a little bye to that
house absolutely but that's my biggest
bug beer is people that have
read a book about proper source and did
not live not got compliant they're
literally just winging it yeah and the
thing is it's like any industry you're
always going to have your good and your
bad and the good will always come to the
top anyway but the bad ones do sort of
give every all the good ones a bit of a
harder time because if they're listening
those people that do that I would say
good for you for trying yeah but just
get yourself educated yeah go on it go
on some training getting talk to people
that are doing it properly and do it
properly the thing is I do get contacted
by sources aren't compliant want me to
sell their deals for them and I won't do
it because I've taken the time and
effort to get educated I've spent a lot
of money to get educated and I'm
compliant and that's why your investors
queuing up that's why I have I'm getting
at the minute between eight and twelve
investors pair day coming on board and
I'm not talking about investors that
I've got no money to spend I'm talking
about investors like one that come on
this morn has got four hundred thousand
pound spends pre-qualified he qualified
400k in about spend and I've seen proof
of funding so I know he's a serious
investor what did you think because you
know that I only do business with my
advanced students yes because I get
people I probably get 100 emails a day
from people you know asking me questions
or saying can we do this can we do this
can you sell this deal or can you mentor
me I'm only going to do business with
people that I'm actually working with
that have paved for training yeah what
did you think when I offered you a
business opportunity where we could set
up a business together with him better
sourced my initial thoughts were why me
honestly why me I thought why of there's
a few Academy members like I think why
me why did you chose choose me to do the
business with obviously I was like very
yeah absolutely I'm gonna do it there
was no question I was gonna do it
because for me it so I'd rather be a
business partner with like yourself then
try and do it on my own yeah it's much
okay so I'm still pretty I put a lot of
effort in I put a lot of work in but
it's made that little bit easier because
I'm involved with yourself yeah and you
your connections are phenomenal yeah
yeah yeah so it's a great opportunity I
was never going to turn it down but yeah
my initial thought was why did you
choose me over everyone else because we
business with a lot of people on the
academy in different ways shapes and
forms and different people want
different things
yeah I don't know as you say to people
that are doing well on the Academy what
do you want yeah what do you want and
then they'll like Stuart said I want to
speak in front of a hundred people yeah
in Africa who are budding entrepreneurs
I'm like duh
Leslie said I want to get myself in the
papers and raise my brand I want to be a
best-selling author I'm like done making
it happen so that's kind of how I roll
what would you say to someone who was
considering going on your list to get
deals in fact let me see what old I'll
answer that questions go on
I would aside to somebody that was
thinking about going on your list how do
you sign up to your list hey so if you
go on to my website which is
www.hyken.com
I think you are probably the best deal
sorcerer in the country your integrity
your word is your bond yeah you get when
you say you're gonna do what you do it
you only pass deals on the I know you
would by yourself yeah I would never
knowingly pass a deal that is know and
if you do mess out like up if you do
mess up you put it right yeah absolutely
we've had a time you don't mess up much
but I've seen twice where you've sold a
deal there was an issue which for you
unforeseen circumstances the naked eye
over this Arabiya yeah and then you've
just boom put it right yeah so in that
case we had an issue with the survey the
property come back as having issue with
the joists we I can't tell that one with
you because we're not like to lift
floorboards so what we done was we spoke
to the investor we the best of their
investors are serious investor so he
knows these things happen and I
explained him look you can have a full
refund or we can find you another
property
what do you want to do and in this case
he said I'll start it was just keep the
money it was when you get a next another
suitable property let me know and we'll
go from there so what I've done with
this guy is he's now top of my list any
property we get come along he gets first
refusal on it yeah and and I'll walk
with him no until he's completely happy
and if six months pass and he's not
found a property I'll just oh give him
as refund because yeah he's he's given
me time if I can't fulfill that in six
months I failed him yeah so I'm a man in
the ward I know I know as well
because I see obviously the bank when
you take a fee you know you don't spend
it it's so it sits in a Holdings account
yeah until the house gets completely the
right way to do it so I would say if
someone's thinking of of doing it you've
got app so you know it doesn't even at
the moment it doesn't cost it to be on
your nobody probably well at the moment
it's free that I am getting asked by a
lot of investors how they can get access
before everyone else because yeah the
deals sell very quick I would say if
you're listening to this and you're an
investor and you're wanting to get some
someone to do all the hard work for you
get down to better source limited code
UK get on the list if you're wanting to
find your own deals I think I don't need
to come to the crash course yeah 100%
with an open mind yeah ready to you know
do everything that said yeah 100% yeah
what was it like working with my it's a
blast know that he's no day's the same
every day is different
every crash course is different yeah
everything I me up your law we spend
time to go because we're business
partners and we were we're doing well we
were doing business together and I'm
doing really well so we we have
opportunities and things are it's just
awesome yeah how do I operate in
business with the Academy members with
you it's very much if you move one so
like me I I've gone out and I've done
deals and you've like I move one you
move ten yeah I give you one thing in
your late great what now what does Italy
and then you're like BAM just do this I
had a guy actually called Keegan law and
he phoned me up they didn't phone me
drop yet he wasn't an advanced unit just
came on the crash course he dropped me a
Facebook message I happened to see it
and he said hey I've just got a property
new it's completed today and I found it
on the crash course I'm gonna go and
pick up the keys want to come and I just
thought you know what I would never
normally do that but because he's a
young guy he's made so much commitment
he's got a property from the crash
course he's reached out to me I just
responded sure what time when our picked
up the keys with him in fact if you want
to watch that video it will come up on
the on the thing just right now above my
head you can click it and you can watch
that video of him and the property but
that's fantastic so what would your
final words of encouragement or advice
be to anybody listening or watch
my advice listen don't lay your little
voices and your negativity ruin you
because that's what happened to me so I
spent seven years listening to my
negativity telling me that everything
that I'm not good for this I'm not
deserving of success just freakin do it
you don't worry about it don't care what
your friends think don't care about your
family thing obviously don't upset them
but just just do I think you set them
this is your life it's not their life
yeah you've just got to do whatever
you've got to do to get what you want to
achieve so for me I've always wanted to
be in property so last year I met Samuel
by watching watching him on TV and
reading his book and I was like that guy
is 27 years old or 26 at the time I'm
like I'm 35 he's 10 years my junior and
it's like he's so much more what the
hell was going on he's so much more
successful than me so I just have to
find them and I had to meet him and I
had to learn what he's doing and I'd III
am a great believer in copy the rich guy
why I caught don't don't listen to me
it's only in the pub they are not the
successful ones yeah the people that are
doing it and actually making money from
it
yeah people make excuses sometimes well
that's great by the way like doubt
they'll see reviews somewhere of someone
saying oh I didn't like the question
course very much
and they'll think ah okay and then
they'll have that as a reason you know
why not to go yeah because one person
out of 500 people yeah said that but
that's probably the one person who's
broke yeah who is actually blaming the
crash course on their lack of results
because rather than saying oh you know
what crash course was great but I didn't
do anything because I'm lazy and and my
mindset is broke and I'm a bum so that's
why I'm not successful they'd rather say
I'm not successful because the crush
girls didn't go through in enough detail
or whatever so they're always the lame
yeah rather than rather than actually
take responsibility yeah I mean it
doesn't matter what business you're in
you're always been our people you love
are people that love you and people that
don't like you doesn't matter what
business you're in now although it's say
it to people that are reading the views
there's hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of great reviews just because
there's one or two they didn't
particularly like the crash course or
didn't particularly like Samuel does
that really matter although it says
read them all with an open mind and do
you know what
you cannot keep everyone happy Samuel
says for every hundred people he's
helped there's always one he's not or
when he's upset
it's that right I say for every one
hater you've helped one hundred
something okay I was merely right yeah
but my point being is listen read oh if
you're going to read the views read them
but don't just listen to the the
negative ones listen to all of them read
all of them and there's far more good
than the end of the day it doesn't
matter because no one's success is down
to me all I can do is give the toolbox
yeah give the instruction manual that's
it
yeah so no one successes down to me your
success is because of you in fact there
was someone on the crash course or one
of the training programs in the you guys
who was sat next to you yeah I'm the
same program where she now no way yeah
and she Oh true very true and and now
you're killing it she was on the same
program sat next to you
now she's nowhere to be seen yeah so
it's down to you I gave you the toolbox
I gave you the instruction manual and
cheered you won but you did it you can
take a horse to water but you can't make
you drink no that's fun percent true
like you say it's very true you've given
us a toolbox but it's up to us what we
choose to do with that yeah I've choose
to make it work yeah I've gone on and
used them tools effectively and Anthony
was left right and center I hope people
take them tool boxes and just leave them
in the garage
yeah that's up to them also the way I am
I worked out a long time ago that some
people are going to like you just
because and other people won't like you
because of the color of your t-shirt or
the color of your skin you know so
whatever no matter how you are there's
gonna be some people that like you some
people that don't so you may as well
just do whatever you want
be completely honest be completely real
and be you and then some people will
like you some people won't
so when I'm training I'll be I'm you've
seen firsthand sometimes I can be quite
direct yeah but I like that I think
that's nice I tell people as it is if
someone if someone you know starts start
screaming of excuses I'll tell them yeah
well if someone says I did this program
it didn't work and then I did this
program it didn't work and then this
person ripped me off and then this
happened and then I got a divorce and
then it got her three divorces and then
they suffer
I'll say he and they'll use that as an
excuse but I'll say there's a common
denominator in this problem and it's you
so what can we do to change this pattern
and because the same wind blows on a
saudis the setting of the sail that
determines the destination
yeah I agree that so I'll be quite
direct and so we don't like that no I
like your directness because there's too
many people want that will sort of beat
around the bush yeah they won't come out
and see what they want and all that does
is delay things I would rather you be
direct to me it's like when I've done my
first introduction of you yeah you were
a direct I also it sucked yeah I'm like
great thank you very much no one who I
can make it me then I told you how it
could be better yes so you didn't just
see also--it's socks and make me feel
tiny use it also it sucks and once you
pulled yourself up off the floor from
laughing so much I realized that I said
I said great ISU's bad I told you what
is bad I told you what to do yeah and
then and then we made it we made it
better so that's great I'm really I'm
really honored to be a friend of yours
I'm really excited to see your future
and I'm really glad to be poor Jenny
so thanks for coming on the show and
thank you I see you having me I'll see
you in Africa next week in Monday yeah
and tomorrow yeah basically all the time
because you're in a caddy remember yeah
and if you're watching this get down to
the crash course put yourself on now
spaces are so limited they always sell
out usually I think right now there's
like a two or three month waiting list
as I'm speaking right now so get
yourself booked on and go to
www.instanteulogy.com that video please
do share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time